[Music]
that's like a samurai movie where
there's a duel and there's like Rose
what's called cherry balls right yeah
like that [ __ ] dope yeah did you ever
did you ever pretend to be a samurai
when you're a kid and just play that
burden even now [ __ ] samurai armor
and The Hobbit he has it in his office
right now I'm pretty sure next to the
Cape and the [ __ ] furries outfit as
soon as we're gone who's gonna vote
quarter and I used to love samurai [ __ ]
man there's this cartoon when I was a
kid called Ronin Warriors did you guys
watch that [ __ ] no no you didn't have a
childhood so you don't care yeah you're
really familiar if you see you would
know what it is it was like right at the
Dragon Ball Z in the morning oh yeah so
like Ronin Warriors was like the [ __ ]
and it kind of glorified with samurais
were and then would actually find out
what they were and kind of took away all
the clear not dark a game - it was -
what a lot of people don't know about
samurais is like for about a hundred
years there was no war so they're just
like glorified politicians with [ __ ]
the license to kill and they just
bullied people
well cuz they had the power to know
they're more like politicians with
swords what about the ones before were
they warriors before after the I think
it was like three hundred years of war
some kind of mountain there just
non-stop war and then when Japan unified
there was no more reason to war so then
they're just like in armor preparing for
what and that's if you guys were put
back into that time frame yeah do you
guys I'm David this is not for you but
do you two guys think that you guys
would be warriors I don't understand why
it's not for me
do you think you can rise to the
occasion and be a warrior that leads
people into the fold this is not for me
one half of my family their lineage so
like by the last name that you have you
know because Japan had a caste system
yeah so it's like it's you're either
from us our samurai class you're from
royalty you're from a merchant class
you're from a farmer fisherman or
whatever fisherman artist yeah craftsman
or artist clown
yeah cloudy but you know what your pot
your pretty up there yeah yeah
there's no part of the royal court
business merchants and business we're at
the very bottom nice try trying to
assault me he's on a unicycle at the
bottom there's the untouchables they're
not even citizens they're not even
humans oh that's yeah they're like
foreigners people people that do like
like all the unclean work like cutting
[ __ ] pigs or whatever making leather
whatever I would like to see my
collecting Sookie just heaven where's
your lineage from and you stopped you oh
yeah half of it is a fish fishermen and
half of it is warrior cool cool what's
how do you think you got I love killing
fish you're so drawn to weapon maybe
maybe it was in the blood I don't know
but the funny thing is that year of
hundred years of peace that's where the
development of like jiu-jitsu and all
that stuff came because it was like it
had so much [ __ ] time to get good at
[ __ ] without dying
yeah all those years of just practicing
for no war that's ever coming have you
guys seen any movies yourself but I just
saw the one with the movie was it go
shot the [ __ ] up was that movie cop a
quiet place yeah you know it is it scary
so it's a thriller right so there's a
lot there's a lot of jumps it's not a
horror film so it's not gonna stick with
you in that creepy technicon but it's
very suspenseful and it's interesting
because most of that film is silent oh I
liked it a lot
quiet it's a it's I usually like
dialogue I mean that's like the thing I
like films is depending on how great the
dialogue is but this one it didn't
really need it it was kind of
predictable you could tell what was
gonna happen at the end but it didn't
really matter just because like it was
so intense I liked it my place was dope
did you guys see you ready player one
and I had no knowledge of it before I
didn't read it to remind you of the old
Spielberg movies like directed it just
felt like there were parts where it just
felt so like baby I like the way it is
dated or nostalgic not nostalgia like
the acting and like the the way I don't
know I I can't like break it I didn't
have the um what's the [ __ ] Netflix
original sure you didn't have the
stranger things type of feel to it
no no no I had like like witty lines
like corny like like [ __ ] you're stuck
in the 90s yeah just to me it felt like
oh he hasn't evolved with the with the
filmmaking time but I thought it was
really entertaining and I really liked
the CGI and everything it was really
cool yeah I thought that would bother me
but now I heard he [ __ ] children
there's a conspiracy that I'm not naming
no names but like I watch a lot of
conspiracy videos on YouTube that he
likes children no but I mean they say
almost everybody in Hollywood and
politicians like children yeah a
prerequisite to be somebody really
successful in Hollywood you have to be a
sick [ __ ] freak like all it like
these like up or
on actors directors there's some [ __ ]
sick twisted human beings I'm not weird
enough to be successful in this space or
maybe you become weird when you're there
yeah I know the story overdue who's just
he was super rich and he became a
pedophile he didn't become a pedophile
but like he was so rich that he was
smashing all these chicks all the time
and he got to the plane feels like I'm
tired of smashing chicks because he had
too much of this and this is what
happens after you have too much dick
kids see too many kids though why are
guys kids women that's true just like
mental breakdown that's not true they
just don't talk about it yeah gotta dump
out all the teachers who have sex with
their students way more women they don't
even need to be successful to [ __ ] kids
weirdos we're talking about normal
people that just end up like escalating
like the way you guys are people that
the natural trajectory carry yeah she'd
ever know her [ __ ] is different she
[ __ ] Nick Cannon your mom but I'm
saying he became bipolar
that's her [ __ ] so the guys also have
problems - no no more normal guys aren't
[ __ ] animals they're all [ __ ] up in
the head yeah imagine the future we find
out like people that we really respect
like women they end up doing some crazy
[ __ ] that it comes out like crazy like a
dog or something like their dog that
they always take I feel like see that's
the problem
well dude you just knit you just nailed
the problem right there
is people should not respect anyone they
don't know personally cuz that's me like
they oh who do you look up to who do you
I'm like yeah I mean their
accomplishments are great but you don't
know who they're [ __ ] true the only
person I know for sure is Michael
Jackson he's safe yeah yeah because it's
the media that [ __ ] with him but anybody
else do not give up are you with that
more I hate when people like put their
own standards or their own insecurities
on other people that they look up to
I agree like yeah let's let's applaud
their hard work and their achievements
or whatever and that's not be haters in
that way but when they do something
that's normal to them which you don't
even know what that is don't be like oh
I thought you were better than yeah look
up to people I only look up to people
for that thing right like it's like
Conor McGregor whatever like it's
because he's he's a great fire yeah I
don't know if he has good food choices
or whatever yeah yeah like I just hate
that me Gor like ol Mayweather you're so
great but you're a bad role model cuz
you can't read you can't read Mayweather
that means that fool gets like like
death threats every day but he doesn't
care I will [ __ ] kill you can't read
this [ __ ] cuz he can't read
he can't read you - dude when he called
his ass off for not being able to read
that she's so [ __ ] funny that was
like literally on YouTube but he can't
read any of the hate I can't read this
[ __ ] anyway they don't matter everybody
love me he can read just not at a high
level Mae Mae Mae show name it's a [ __ ]
your license like you can't read you
know like you have great levels of
probably reads out a fifth grade level
or yeah you know things like that like
so if you give him like a novel and it
has all these words it could be like I
don't know what that is and he'll get
stuck on words he won't be able to just
read through but he knows he was at a
press conference and they slit him a
piece of paper and they froze oh really
not [ __ ] around I mean I think that
first came out from 50 cent when they
were a feud and he put that out there
but then later did a [ __ ] number on a
lot of people later we heard like him
doing drops for I Heart Radio and like
it was so many takes he just couldn't
yourself funny dude that's hilarious I
guess it doesn't really matter you punch
people in the face and you have a
billion dollars yeah but still I could
always hold that over them in the
conversation for sure as a hater when
you don't have [ __ ] then you're like
well at least I cream up exactly you got
that one card cuz if you're like going
back and forth with Mayweather right
he's like I have a virtue you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you ain't got no money you can't but
he wins still billion dollars I'm the
highest paid athlete and I you know
thanks still make my life is way better
than yours and I can't even read
did you see it's Christmas tree though
oh my god go on his Instagram his
Christmas tree is know what I saw was
like wow that's extravagant that's I
figured as much you [ __ ] travels with
a duffel bag full [ __ ] million a
million dollars have you heard of the
story between you know why you're his
hit him and his father they've had like
a falling-out for a certain amount have
you heard of their story it's pretty
[ __ ] crazy - this is thousand jail
his dad went to jail because he was like
selling drugs of [ __ ] right oh but his
father would be obviously his father's a
boxer great Network everything else like
that so his nickname was like Floyd joy
married Mayweather so during the time
when he was boxing he wasn't making a
lot of money he was selling drugs with
his brother-in-law well professionally
bought yeah so they were making a lot of
money so his brother-in-law
he had an altercation some about drugs
like granted by the you know scholars
had threatened him he ran off came back
to his house later that night had a
shotgun to his face he grabbed
Mayweather his son the boxer held him up
to his body to shield right and he was
like he's I know you're not gonna shoot
my son so I'm not gonna let go of my son
right
so instead what a big hit so instead
what he what he does he didn't shoot him
in the face he shoots Floyd joy
Mayweather in the cap and his boxing
career his his brothers actually
continued their boxing career and that's
who you know who trains Mayweather yeah
his uncle yeah yeah uncle so his uncle
was trading amok he went to jail later
on for selling drugs but that's like his
his upbringing was [ __ ] harsh but his
dad originally not I'm out of oz' your
own father uses you as a shield dear
it clearly had problems I held up him be
I held him up because I knew he was
gonna kill my son so I knew for a fact
it wasn't gonna happen that was the only
way I was going to survive that's not a
point [ __ ] keep your kid out of
danger you fool with me when I talk
about that if it was traumatization
I mean I'm a whether it doesn't really
talk about it but his dad talked about
it in an interview but if you kind of
think about it like that it's so
interesting like how I say it like
things happen for a reason because his
father not dying his father was actually
the one that trained him up until he was
like 17 or 18 years old so maybe he
won't even got into possible so but the
moral the story is at that moment Floyd
said my whole game is gonna be defense
yeah he's godly with the offense dude he
defended his dad he defect that was if
you look at his old boxing Clips [ __ ]
fast ass jab dude his jab is quickest
but yeah yeah but you know he ended with
the shotgun too is [ __ ] careful I
can't I can't hate on new-money behavior
either cuz I'm [ __ ] new money and like
the way I see it is like if you [ __ ]
made that on your own and you never had
much you have every [ __ ] right to
flaunt that [ __ ] cuz it's like
good job you can't really say much to me
whether either sighs I look at you you
irresponsible [ __ ] my dad used me as a
shield from a shotgun yeah I'm like you
deserve it okay I don't care if you
wanna be flashy and do all that because
of course I'm with you they earned it do
you but at the same time you live with a
bunch of other people on this planet so
please be [ __ ] respectful of that
don't spit on the ground don't let your
kids pee public no that's not new money
that's just bad I mean like new money is
like dating a LV print [ __ ] grap
around your your your Bentley yeah and
like I'm fine with you spending your
[ __ ] crazy but yeah why do we need to
know anything I do that's cool is cool
if I don't tell you about it still they
act like it's not cool unless everybody
knows like you got a [ __ ] nice car
you like that car right we don't need to
know more
that's like that's like flossing right
yeah yeah it's like what's the point of
telling all of us just do you [ __ ]
I can't do that either though I'm okay
but other people do it but I can't I
can't get myself to do it that's just
not your personality
no like I can't wear five watches just
because yeah but you can wear fur and a
cape
yes that's but see that's so funny
though it's not a real fur make other
people jealous yeah like that's that's
the mango and that's still yes that
brings the negativity you're trying to
stun on someone yeah well that's what it
is though that's why people get bad when
they were like you know like basic
clothes but it's hella expensive and
nobody says anything they they have to
let you know what it is because nobody
would [ __ ] notice your white t-shirt
that cost three hundred dollars in
they're like oh did you know where I got
this from I don't give a [ __ ] yeah well
people that kind of father they're like
oh yeah I just got this [ __ ] like you
know like the easy line of [ __ ] you
would never know what the [ __ ] it is
unless somebody yeah it was easy [ __ ]
that's why what new money does is they
get Alvey [ __ ] print shirt or like
the big biggest [ __ ] Gucci they could
ever find or whatever big brand has to
show but then the classy way of doing it
is just like not a lot just and you just
know because the ones that know the
brand you oh yeah that's classless I
just think it's preference what do you
mean big it is classless though it
depends on how you do because if some
people's like I want to buy expensive
things because I like them yes other
people's like I want to buy expensive
things so people can know I have
expensive some ugly but it's like you
know how much it cost though there's why
some of the most unfashionable people
wear supreme yeah they just work because
they want people to see supreme even
though it's like the yahoos [ __ ]
thing I've ever seen in my life on the
cheap this shirts yeah yeah shirts bro
like shoes too like a lot of shoes that
cost like crazy amounts of money and
they're all ugly Alvey shoes are fogged
up I'm sorry
mother ugly they're super tacky what's
it called when they did the the [ __ ]
chucks in the Saint Laurent the [ __ ]
was about the the collapse thing that
they did where he just has like the the
[ __ ] hard on it and [ __ ] those are
the you know what that's like
it's what the [ __ ] why is this [ __ ] so
[ __ ] expensive yeah you know it's the
I can I can see why it gets that way
because so like for example if your mega
[ __ ] rich right and then you're going
to all these clothing stores like Old
Navy or whatever you're like [ __ ]
everybody looks the [ __ ] same no
matter where you go in the u.s. everyone
buys [ __ ] at the mall they look the same
and I don't know what you're gonna be
like I'm royalty I want to wear a
[ __ ] first shoe with like I don't
know like a bra for a hat or like they
want to do some next-level [ __ ] they
want to look like Zohan and [ __ ] you
know rich people could do that [ __ ] cuz
they're rich you know I mean who the
poor and you do that [ __ ] you guys are
weird there's this Indonesian prince
that I follow he dresses like this on a
daily he looks like he's steampunk
all the time oh yeah it looks dope and
I'm like that's why they do this it
makes sense but I don't know for me I'm
like I want to do that on a swap meet
level yeah that's an I try to do it with
my clothes
so I only shop at forever 21 cuz its
they have like the stuff that's in but
they usually cost a lot of money but
they'll make it hella cheap cuz they
don't care though they'll have these
lawsuits left and right for like sealing
designs but they don't care well I don't
know those clothing service stuff now
where you get like an outfit every
[ __ ] month for a lot of people the
subscription one's too cheap to like buy
anything you know like [ __ ] is too
expensive I don't want to spend like 40
you know how they get you is when you
don't send that [ __ ] back they just
charge you for everything and they
charge you full price and I'm like I
could get the same thing but cheaper
quality level but it's the same
the same quality it's not but it's not
for people like you though that messed
up is for people who literally can't
dress to save their life so they need
somebody like a stylist to come in and
they'll go like hey this is gonna look
good on you based on your measurements
your height and what you want so it's
not for somebody like you at all
so it's made for people who have no
wardrobe and they don't have a closet so
it builds up their closet and it gives
them staples so a lot of people who
don't wear clothes they don't have
clothing staples they don't have a basic
button-up they don't have like black
shirt white shirt gray shirt they don't
have that [ __ ]
so I think like that kind of stuff for
anybody who has never dressed up in a
day in their life and they want to look
somewhat good try this [ __ ] out you know
why can't we just be like dogs and have
one outfit so the day I die one outfit
any occasion you do and you but you
decide our society tells you you have to
cover it up with a bunch of other [ __ ]
[ __ ] or I'll go to jail
yeah like so how the hell did we protect
ourselves from the elements you know
where we just got naked I think we just
got [ __ ] up but we just dealt with it
we was area cold
yeah well you're still pretty naked yeah
if you see like equator live in
hunter-gatherers they're always naked
yes and it is my grateful for like if we
stayed our natural habitats or better
adapted for those things yeah we're
already out of our geographical zone
like a [ __ ] so we acclimate to the
weather oldest rep my body gets cold
warm whatever let's just all go buy
stuff with giant logos and stop again
haters I'm down let's do it grab some
eyes dominate humbly barbell brigade
stuff it's right there
[Music]